اي مواجهه بيننا وامريكا ستكون كارثه على
العالم هكذا تقول الصين والجميع يصدق حتما
لكن ايا من الطرفين لا يسعى لهذه الحرب
ظاهريا على الاقل وزير الدفاع الصيني وبعد
مصافحه بارده مع نظيره الامريكي خلال
مؤتمر حول الانف سنغافوره اكد ان بلاده
تسعى للحوار وليس المواجهه ليرمي
المسؤوليه فيها كذا حرب لو اندلعت على
امريكا فالوزير الصيني المتربع على عرش
ثالث اقوى جيش في العالم قال ان مسؤوليه
اي توتر تقع على الدول التي تنشر قواعدها
العسكريه وتعزز سباق التصلح في المنطقه
محذرا واشنطن من عوده عقليه الحرب البارده
التي تزكي المخاطر الامنيه طبعا وزير
الدفاع الصيني لا يمكن ان يطرح هكذا موضوع
دون الحديث عن تايوان ليؤكد مجددا بانها
شان داخلي للصين وان بعض الدول تتدخل فيه
بسوء نيه
وزير الدفاع الصيني الذي استخدم التلميح
في تحذيراته اكد ان زوبعه صراعات قادمه
بسبب المساعي لاقامه تحالفات عسكريه شبيهه
بحلف النيتو في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
فمن وجهه نظر بكين هذه المحاولات وسيله
لاختطاف في دول المنطقه وتضخيم الصراعات
والمواجهات الامر الذي لن يؤدي سوى الى
اغراق منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ في زوبعه
من النزاعات والصراعات ولكي ياخذ الجميع
تحضيرات على محمل الجد ذكر الوزير الصيني
الجميع بكوارث الحرمين العالميتين الاولى
والثانيه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات